que voulez-vous vous avertir vous et
votre organisation il éit à l avant mais
il déplace dans le monde une V vous
savez des choses que vous devriez
ignorer il veuttruire re
[Musique]
rouge il y a quelques années un
programme a vu le jour en Europe pour
choisir les meilleurs agents de chaque
pays le roi ou la reine rou elle
s'appelle Antonia Scott c'est une femme
de 34 ans qui a un intellectuel de 42 ça
fait beaucoup ça fait que c'est la
personne la plus intelligente du
monde on voit que dalle comment tu sais
où tu vas grâce à ma mémoire j'aimerais
que vous soyez l'Écuyer de notre Reine
Rouge prêt pour le
spectacle qu'est-ce que tu vois Scott
l'assassin a introduit une canule dans
sa carotide et l' drainé littéralement
il va
recommencer la police n'est pas au
courant personne n'est au courant de
tout ça j'avais jamais rien vu d'aussi
bien planifié tu penses là même chose
que moi non c'est impossible qu'on pense
la même chose tia est de
retour le ravisseur qu'est-ce qu'il veut
il n'a rien demander je veux qu'il soit
retiré de l'enquête tout de suite il
nous MTE depuis le début je ne veux plus
de secret réfléchir c'est pour les gens
comme vous et moi est qu'elle est fait
est
différent police tu sais qu'on voit pas
la même chose là où tu vois quelque
chose de beau je vois des données tu as
inventé ce fantôme pour essayer de
surmonter ta douleur c'est pas un
fantôme qui m'a fait ça j'ai mis ma vie
entre tes mains un type étrange il y a
un autre cerveau derrière tout
ça les enfants payent toujours pour les
péchés de leurs parents sans
exception oh de merde oh
[Musique]
oh